well we talked about josh fleming in the
open and these are his two lines against
the blue jays his major league debut was
very good and then that start against
the marlins down in miami five and a
third scoreless innings and you know
what he has shown us is a very good
sinking fastball he's got good command
of it not afraid to use it on both sides
of the plate the two outs of the base is
empty here's garrett cooper
here's adamus at short stop handling the
chopper three ground ball outs vintage
fleming bottom half of ending one coming
no score
pablo lopez gets the ball on a friday
night in saint pete looking to end the
marlins losing streak against these rays
and looking to keep up what he has been
doing so well g-man choice stands in
ball and two strikes here on g-man choi
[Applause]
and he beats him with the fastball
upstairs wendell was able to beat it out
no review and now here's austin meadows
two balls and two strikes and a
strikeout for pablo lopez two in the
first we're scoreless
josh forming back out for a second
inning as jesus aguilar the former ray
gets ready to dig on in we did not see
him in miami because he was battling a
bulky back now the two two from fleming
swinging and a mess
he struck him out as aguilar becomes the
first strikeout victim so one out base
is empty for yoshi 2-2 pitch he sends a
high-fly ball into center martay looking
for it he's looking for it and that ball
is going to carry out of here
home run for satsugo and that ball
disappeared over the wall in center and
sensugo
on his sixth home run
has given the raise a one-nothing lead
dickenson's first came back at tropicana
field since he last played for the raise
in 2017.
is arm side is this one down the left
field line short wall down there and
it's going to get out
a solo homer for corey dickerson tucks
it just over that short wall in the left
field corner made famous of course by
evan longoria
fifth homer for dickerson in a 1-1 game
yeah well and here's the thing it was a
complete misfire on a change-up
[Applause]
deep short
long throw for thomas and a dandy scoop
on the stretch over there by choi
that was picture perfect look at
g-man go out and get it on the
backhanded scoop i'm on the il dwayne
here's jesus aguilar
aguilar with a fly ball left field that
is going to send meadows back and it's
gone a home run for jesus aguilar
against his former club
yeah hopefully that gets aggielar going
heating up fifth home run of the season
now it's always fun to get your former
team
big swing here two solo homers have the
marlins in front so the first two men
are aboard that's the first lopez walk
in the ball game
when he lines it into right that's going
to fall for a base hit brenson with the
pickup wendell turns third and he's
going to stop there the bases will be
loaded one out away from getting out of
this his 30th pitch of the inning
and ball four
that will force home a run kiermeier
draws the bases loaded walk and it's a
tie game michael perez who fanned his
first time as a chance to give the raise
the lead
and a lighter into left center field
dickerson's going to have to chase this
one that's going to go all the way to
the wall extra bases
meadows has scored satsugo scores it's a
two base hit perez comes through and the
rays grab the lead
back to back two out hits brenson is two
for two and runners at first and second
for john birdie we're starting to see
the hits fall in and now birdie toward
right center field that sends kiermeier
back and it's in and out of his glove
that's going to score alfaro brinson
rounding third he will score and now the
marlins are down a run
here we go marlins fans two-hour magic
starting again on this road trip that
ball well struck and he gave himself a
shot my goodness that close
and vessia has walked to zugo to load
the bases manuel margot with wendell at
third base meadows hit second and two go
at first ready for a 3-2 pitch and a
cold strike three bottom of the zone
it's still five to four marlins walk a
tightrope in the fifth should be matt
joyce and it will be matt joyce to hit
for brinson three on the right side of
the infield against joyce who's gonna
hit it over that shift and it's gonna
get to the wall takes a funny hop and
kind of hugs the wall it'll be an easy
stand-up pinch-hit double marte's
already had a few big hits for the
marlins
ground ball to short adamus goes the
short way it took one pitch and
fairbanks is out of the jam and the
raise maintain the lead the end of the
ninth inning at tropicana field the rays
are three outs away from a win and nick
anderson back off the injured list is
coming on to try to save it against his
former team the miami marlin
and a ground ball adamus gets to it
can't get it out of his glove and
they're both safe adamus had a double
play ball in his hands and alfaro at the
plate with the tying run in scoring
position go ahead run at first
ground ball third backhanded stop out at
third down and second safe there so
wendell gets the out at third on the
diving stop he just plopped on the bag
for the force there but now the marlins
are down to their final out
3-2
and strength recall this game is over
birdie didn't like the call
he is caught looking and the rays win
this one five to four